DANNY: Las Vegas Golden Knights
goalie, Marc-Andre Fleury, came
to us with a dream that he's had
in his head of a wicked muscle
car that he's always wanted.
We tracked down this Chevelle,
got his stamp of approval
on it being the right car, and
we went to work on this thing.
Let me tell you-- this
baby is cool as ice.
Marc is here today
to check it out.
Come on, brother.
- As I was here?
- No way.
It ain't here yet.
I hope he fulfilled
this man's dreams.
Ryan, my brother, come on!
Bring out Marc's car.
[music playing]
[engine revving]
Sounds good.
DANNY: Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
[laughs] I'm just watching him.
- Oh my god.
She looks awesome.
DANNY: Oh, yeah.
[engine revving]
Oh, man, that's awesome.
DANNY (VOICEOVER):
Marc said he wanted
a fun and sinister car he
could drive the kids around in.
Talk about an interesting
combo-- but right up our alley.
On the outside, we started with
a glossy jet black paint job
and added matte black
18-inch Ridler wheels
to complement that badass look.
Inside, Paulie did his thing--
complimenting that
beautiful black exterior
with a blood red
interior and bench seats
shaped like buckets in the front
for a unique and comfortable
look.
Then finally, Marc
wanted the car to be fun.
So we put in an
LS2 engine pushing
500 horsepower, Hooker Headers,
and Borla dual exhaust.
We also equipped this baby with
tubular control arms, front
and rear coilovers, and Wilwood
brakes all the way around
so that he'll be driving
in comfort and style
while having fun every
time he steps on the gas.
[engine revving]
[laughs]
Oh, that's awesome.
You know, and-- and that's why
going to the LS motor was great
because when you're on the
road, you know, traveling,
and you do a lot of that,
you just come home--
it's sitting in your garage.
It just will start
up every time.
You don't even have
to hit the gas.
It sounds wicked,
though, right?
- It sounds awesome, yes.
- Right on.
So you've got tubular control
arms in your suspension.
You've got coilover suspension
in all four corners.
So it's fully
adjustable for height,
and dampening, and stiffness,
and things like that.
Paulie went crazy with
that beautiful canvas top.
Usually, you know, on the muscle
cars, they do, like, that--
like, a vinyl convertible top--
high-end canvas top on it.
I wasn't too sure either.
I didn't know if I should have
went all blacked out, right?
But I really like the
little touches of chrome
around the car.
I think it puts it
together, right?
RYAN: It's perfect.
You did a hell of a job.
The black--
No.
You did a hell of a job.
RYAN: --blacking
out the bumpers--
I wasn't too sure about--
MARC-ANDR FLEURY: The
black bumpers, yeah?
RYAN: But man,
changed the whole car.
DANNY: I like them.
It's just really
sinister back here.
MARC-ANDR FLEURY: Yeah.
Looking good.
DANNY: You know?
RYAN: This is my favorite part.
MARC-ANDR FLEURY: Yeah.
In the trunk?
KEVIN: This is fantastic.
DANNY: Bam.
Just like your interior.
MARC-ANDR FLEURY: Perfect.
It compartments
your stereo setup.
So you got a lot of
sound in the car.
But you don't see it.
That still can
fit my hockey bags.
So it's--
RYAN: Exactly.
KEVIN: It's perfect.
MARC-ANDR FLEURY: Yeah.
That's good.
Sticks out the window,
bag in the trunk?
[laughter]
I've been there.
I love it.
Thump.
I think we should
look under the hood.
Yeah.
DANNY: You perform on
the ice constantly.
So you wanted something
that's American muscle
that you can drive every day
and have your performance.
So hiding under
here is a gorgeous--
MARC-ANDR FLEURY: Jeez.
Yeah.
DANNY: --LS2.
I like your
little touch there.
Absolutely-- pushing
just about 500 horse--
Really?
Yeah?
DANNY: --in this car.
It can get up there?
DANNY: Absolutely.
MARC-ANDR FLEURY: I know.
It looks awesome.
DANNY: Feels good?
MARC-ANDR FLEURY: Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
For sure.
[laughs]
Jeez.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Good.
I-- I know.
I know.
I don't want to touch it.
So Marc, now that you are a
classic American muscle car
owner--
- Yeah.
--how you feeling about it?
Pretty good.
DANNY: I got to
say, I dig the car.
But most importantly,
I'm glad that you dig it.
Thank you.
DANNY: Yeah, man.
So all we ask now is that
you put a big giant cup
in the back seat here.
[laughs]
Yeah.
I'll drive around with it.
DANNY: Drive down with
a big cup in the back.
And-- your key.
- Thank you.
Absolutely, man.
Man, I got to tell
you-- having an NHL
hockey team right here in
the desert of Las Vegas
is seriously sweet.
Having one that went
to the Stanley Cup
in its very first season--
that's insane.
And Marc-Andr Fleury
was a huge part of that.
And today, I'm so happy
that we made this man
as happy as he made our city.
I'm sure he's looking
forward to hitting
the streets in his
beautiful wicked Chevelle.
And we're looking
forward to watching
the Golden Knights hit the ice
and make this city happy again.
Stanley Cup, here we come!
Man, I'm glad you're happy, bro.
- Yeah.
Thank you.
It makes us happy
to make you happy.
[laughs]
- Appreciate that.
Amen.
Let's go finish this up.
All right.